and we have to increase our efforts
nationally and also on European Union
level in the fight against terrorism the
best way to do is it is in to improve
exchange of information therefore we
need to move on with the painting
limitation of European Union beyond our
directive of implement oral
implementation of automated fingerprint
search modality in the Schengen
information system on the immigration as
a result of many important steps taken
the irregular migration flow on central
Mediterranean has significantly dropped
since the last meeting in Tallinn in
July however we'll have also seen
changes in the eastern and western
Mediterranean roads who are have been
increase in migratory flows during the
last months and therefore who have to
keep working and do so together we have
to put every effort in implementing
return policy cooperating with first
countries you're implementing European
Union turkey agreement statement and and
relocation and also the reception
capacity and conditions in Libya for
migrants need to be improved to stem the
irregular flows to Europe we have three
main priorities continuing our efforts
in and around Libya stepping up returns
and enhancing legal channels both for
protection and legal migration more
generally in two weeks I will present
proposals on how to take yo migration
management to the next level in parallel
it is now urgent that ministers
seriously work towards completing the
reform of the European Common Asylum
system